and for the record by the way this show
would have the same position on kyle
rittenhouse if he was a bernie sanders
voter which we don't know maybe he is he
probably hasn't voted for anybody he's
too young but the point is this is not
partisan
the right to self-defense is the most
basic right any human being has you're
born with it it's innate
and if they try and take that away we're
all in trouble
so as we said at the end of the last
block we want to talk to jason whitlock
and whenever we do we never even ask a
question we just throw it to him and he
always surprises us
in a good way he joins us now he's of
course the host of fearless jason
whitlock great to see you what do you
make of this
tucker i think that
what we've just seen from those 12
jurors
is courage that we needed it's
inspirational to all of us as men and
women it took real courage for them to
do this and and i just want to try to
add this take if i could say one thing
while i'm here because you've been
having this conversation why is
everything being couched this race
this is a calculated strategy
to disarm america to go after the guns
and to eventually rewrite the
constitution
they're trying to define america as a
failure and its number one failure is
along the lines of race and if they can
convince enough of the american public
that this country is irredeemably racist
they now have a justification to rewrite
the constitution start this thing all
over and make us more like china that's
the end game this is not an accident
that from joe biden on down who says
that white supremacy is the biggest
threat to america all the way down to
rachel maddow aka joy reid
constantly talking race race race race
race
this is a strategy that's been quite
effective it hides the agenda
they've convinced black people that
planned parenthood and aborting your
babies is the greatest thing you can do
and anybody that tells you different is
a racist when we know that planned
parenthood and margaret sanger they're
the racist and that the destruction of
black babies in the womb that is the
racist activity
everything it's like they the bigger the
lie they tell it's like the more we
believe we need to recognize they're
lying to us intentionally with a
defined goal of rewriting the
constitution and taking guns away and
sovereignty away from the american
people god that's so that's so smart and
the bigger the lie the more likely
people are to believe it if they're
putting abortion clinics in your
neighborhood they don't love you sorry
obviously um thank you for saying that
jason whitlock really glad to have you
on tonight appreciate it